[Music]
it's hard to believe but Betty White
will turn 95 years young next month and
there is absolutely no sign of her
slowing down we were on the set is Betty
shot her latest TV role is there
something there's our one thing out
there that Betty White still wants to do
I finally found something that Betty
White has it done we have to set up
YouTube mean right oh no if I ever marry
mud fitting that's the secret to being
Betty she's truly humbled you're one of
those folks that your picture pops up
your name is mentioned and people just
follow me oh I think you're exaggerating
no please please know how deeply I
appreciate it when you're walking into
some place and perfect stranger is your
friend and that's that's a great
privilege Betty is guest starring on the
freeform sitcom young and hungry she'll
play a neighbor who's had five husbands
what's the secret to staying so young
and after it's secret no but it's I
think it's good health I'm so healthy
and at 94 you don't expect to be there
healthy
[Music]